يحتفل الاوكرانيون بذكرى الثانيه
والثلاثين الاستقلال بلادهم اجواء الحرب
تغلف الاحتفالات في كل مكان هو العيد
الثاني منذ بدء الحرب قبل اكثر من 18 شهرا
في هذه الذكرى اختار الاوكرانيون تنفيذ
عمليه خاصه في مكان له رمزيه خاصه بالنسبه
اليهم تقول المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان قوات
البحريه والمخابرات العسكريه نفذت عمليه
خاصه وانزلت قوات غربيه شبه جزيره القرم
قرب اولينيكا وماياك ورفعت العلم
الاوكراني حسب اندريه يوسف المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه فقد نفذت القوات
الاوكرانيه كل المهام والحقت خسائر بقوات
روسيه اشتبكت معها ثم انسحبت من موقع
الانزال في المقابل تقول وسائل اعلام
روسيه نقلا عن المخابرات الروسيه ان
الاوكرانيين استخدموا اربعه زوارق مطاطيه
في عمليه الانزال التي شارك فيها ما بين
15 رجلا تم القضاء عليهم جميعا يعد هذا
الانزال تطورا نوعيا في الحرب الدائره
حاليا ففي الفتره الاخيره استهدفت القوات
الاوكرانيه شبه الجزيره بمسيرات جويه
وبحريه وركزت على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيباستوبول وتعد هذه المره
الاولى التي يصل فيها جنود اوكرانيون الى
شبه الجزيره منذ ضمها من قبل روسيا عام
2014 وربطها باليابسه الروسيه عبر جسر
كيرش عام 2018 ترفض موسكو مجرد الحديث عن
التخلي عن شبه الجزيره لكن تياب مصره على
استعادتها في الخطاب الذي وجهه الرئيس
الاوكراني لشعبه في ذكرى عيد الاستقلال
كانت القرم حاضره وعلى ابن ضمير زيدنسكي
بتحرير شبه الجزيره مما وصفه بالاحتلال
الروسي وطالب الاوكرانيين بان لا يفقدوا
الامل وهم يواجهون ظروفا صعبه لم تختفي
الظروف الصعبه في يوم الاحتفال بعيد
الاستقلال قال حاكم ان قصفا صاروقيا روسيا
استهدف المدينه وخلف 10 جرحى على الاقل
وتعرضت خرسون لقصف روسي والحق قصف اخر
اضرارا كبيره بمحطه للكهرباء لتستمر حرب
الاستنزاف بين الطرفين